bonjour c'est assez désarmant vous vous
retrouvez devant des hommes et des
femmes en train de parler des hommes et
des femmes mais parfois moi même je vous
en perdu avec cette nomenclature là vous
allez dans mon travail de tous les jours
je passe de temps à regarder la société
analyse et essaie de comprendre des
réflexions déjanté aujourd'hui on va
essayer de la masculinité et de et du
piège de ce mot mais pour ça je vais
vous emmener un peu dans mon monde
j'ai parlé d'un spectacle non un jour
après un spectacle en sortant j'ai
remarqué que la mallette était perdu ou
fait mal et elle était dans ma voiture
et il y en avait plus quand je suis
sorti et là dedans il y avait les pièces
d'identité mon ordinateur mais tralala
qui utilisent pour au travail dans les
images next événements tristes et que je
dirais que c'est alors fallait que je
passe à notre passeport donc le
lendemain je suis allé aux affaires
étrangères et j'entre dans le bureau de
la personne qui devait m'aider est le
regard bonjour je demandais pourquoi ce
que vous regardez comme cela c'est
conserver d'un extraterrestre
ok on parle et on à la conversation avec
m puis elle me regardait bizarrement au
final me dis ok d'accord monsieur rené
la semaine prochaine pour faire la
capture mais si vous plaît messieurs il
faudrait enlever les prêts ce que vous
avez ok ok j'ai demandé mais presse
mais pourquoi me dit non d'abord vous
êtes vous êtes un garçon et après vous
allez prendre une photo pour un document
officiel et c'est pas approprié pour un
garçon mais j'étais frustré mais c'est
mais j'adore mais presse et pourquoi
donc si je comprends bien je devrais
défaire maîtresse allait prendre une
photo et après on est au salon de
coiffure pour comme on vous passe d'être
est équivalent vous et mon argent donc
vraiment c'était pour moi c'était un peu
de trop alors j'ai fait quelques
recherches sur internet et en faisant
des recherches succombé sur un sur dans
le site de jean louis david raison de la
vie c'était un coiffeur ans coiffeur
français qui dit que les presses s'est
approprié pour les filles certes mais
les filles quand les filles les hommes
peuvent faire peuvent se permettre des
fantaisies quand ils font des 13 mai les
quarts sans les hommes pour eux il
faudrait que ça soit plus sobre mais
cette idée vraiment ça me dérange
ça me dérange parce que je suis un
garçon mais j'adore la fantaisie et jeu
il ya quelque chose dans la voiture n'a
que pour les femmes en voyage on fait
des robes et des formes et des couleurs
et pour les hommes c'est souvent on aux
chromes et c'est ça change pas mais
merde cette histoire voilà donc alors je
me demande pourquoi est-ce que s'il
entend être masculin et à ses limites
limitatif comme comme situation
alors tant que j'aimerais poser à chacun
c'est comment est ce que chacun perthois
la masculinité
mais je me demande que votre si vous pas
faire le tour de la salle un habitacle
mais j'ai demandé à quelqu'un d'autre et
je vous demande de suivre avec moi pour
quand on écoute la réponse de m
je pense c'est tout ce que le gens
attribuent aux à l'homme tous les
comportements que le gens attribuent à
l'homme à un homme c'est à dire le genre
dit que seul homme qui doit faire les
travaux de dur labeur dans un ménage le
genre dit que selon qui doit aller au
travail
le genre dit que l'homme physiquement
doit être musclé doit être fort
physiquement que l'ordre hype autorités
et tout ça l'ensemble de toutes rôles
ces comportements que l'on attribue à
l'homme par le jean est d'appeler la
masculinité la masculinité peut se
retrouver chez l'homme et on peut aussi
relever la masculinité chez une femme il
arrive qu'on dise cette femme et d'une
masculinité incroyable et autant on peut
dire que cet homme est très masculin
autant on peut dire que c'est un et
d'une masculinité jamais vu voilà merci
merci à lui aussi voilà donc en gros
content de moi en pot c'est peut-être à
chaque personne ya des choses qui
reviennent par exemple on dira que une
personne qui est née mal de sexe mâle
devraient être présents gilles quand je
dis pas être portée à la fantasy
cette personne ne devrait pas trop
exprimé ses sentiments et la plupart du
temps se sentir supérieur à la femme ou
encore avoir une orientation
émotionnelle et mentale affective
amoureuse hétérosexuels je vais prendre
dans un autre image on voit deux garçons
que l'on connaît bien
à gauche le garçon à gauche la plupart
pour beaucoup de personnes
sera considérée comme plus viril que le
garçon à droite quand on parle de la
vérité émotionnelle qui a déjà je suis
sûr que certains d'entre vous ont déjà
entendu des propos tels que tu es un
garçon tu dois pas pleurer en public ou
bien quand on voit deux gars en ce sens
brasser il se rend pas bien sa
principale s'est passé pas bienvenue
dans notre société
alors si je dois parler de la finance de
l'homme sur la femme c'est quelque chose
que je comprends pas non plus pourquoi
est-ce que c'est l'homme qui est le chef
de la famille ça j'arrive pas à
comprendre bien pourquoi est-ce que
c'est toujours l'homme qui demande en
mariage et pourquoi c'est la femme
pourquoi ma femme je ne peux pas faire
ça et pourquoi est-ce-que surtout dans
nos sociétés africaines
la polygamie semble plus accepter voire
même encouragé que la polyandrie et
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya des métiers de
20 unités dans pourquoi est-ce qu'on
peut pas avoir un homme au foyer
pourriez quand on en a et c'est mal vu
donc est toutes ces questions qui
montrent comment la domine la domination
l'autorité de l'homme sur la femme et à
la question de l'orientation sexuelle et
hommes c'est celui qui aime les femmes
et c'est celui qui épouse une femme
alors quand on est un peu comme moi ça
veut dire pas musclé j'ai tapé de
chocolat ou bien quand on est homosexuel
comme moi et qu'on est plutôt doux on se
remet en attendant allons remettre un
certain nombre mais dans le droit chemin
être masculin et des gens quand
un forcément des personnes homosexuelles
ça peut être des gens complètement qui
ne rentrent pas dans la définition
générale de la masculinité vivent très
mal cette situation
et en ce sens mal dans ce sens rejeté et
a deux solutions soit allée perd face à
la société soit chercher à ressembler à
ces personnes
cet idéal à et on aura l'impression de
vivre la vie d'une autre personne
alors comme aujourd'hui j'ai besoin de
vous partager quelque chose
c'est une idée de vous dire que je pense
qu'il n'y a pas une seule façon d'être
masculin qui on a plusieurs et je vais
m'inspirer de ma propre vie pour
raconter des histoires question de vous
faire un bon mondial lui exprimer c'est
que je cherchais à extérioriser la
première histoire
en fait je suis un activiste pour la
cause lgbt ya pas longtemps j'ai donné
un article un magazine qui parler
d'homosexualité magazine virtuel c'est
qu'on n'a pas sur internet
alors c'est sûr il y avait beaucoup de
gens qui veulent des commandes et des
propos que je vais homophobes mon disant
que non je vais passer tous les
commentaires mais avec quelqu'un quelle
personne qui arrive et qui dit mais je
me suis retourné au fait j'ai étudié
avec lui au secondaire je le connais en
plus mis les homosexuels ne c'est pas
possible je comprends il était comme une
fille quand on était à l'école est tous
d'accord s'il ya oppression contre un
peu l'image
j'étais ce genre de garçon qui ne parle
pas beaucoup il est toujours dans ses
livres j'avais pas des lunettes
il est toujours dans ses livres et pas
très sportif toujours dans mon coin et
je vivais très mal cela parce que les
gens m'assimile un homosexuel
c'est vrai que j'avais fait je suis
homosexuel mais à l'époque je ne le
réclamait pas parce que c'est qu'il y
avait encore beaucoup de questionnements
moi mais c'est comme si les les enfants
de mon âge cherché à me mettre dans une
case
mais en grandissant on apprend à
réaliser que ok c'est vrai je suis
différent des personnes différentes
versions mais après ça fait quoi
puis en l'acceptant devient plus fort
mais je quand j'entre dans le milieu
professionnel
je me rends compte qu'il ya toujours ces
remises en question parce qu'un jour
j'avais un meeting avec des partenaires
et à la fin du meeting
un des partenaires me dit tu sais ce
qu'elle y je te croirais que le jour le
jour que tu puisses retz commune est
placée pour moi je me demandais mais le
jeu que je me serais comme une femme
pour cette personne la personne était
convaincu que j'étais une femme parce
que je faisais détresse ont peut-être je
sais pas pour vous mais je sais qu'elle
a l'habitude de le travailler avec des
personnes changeant et peut-être pour
lui quand on est un homme que il ya des
choses qui collent pas
d'après lui si ça sous-entend qu'on est
sûrement 30 jan mais pour moi c'était
très développé et on peut se dire que
c'est parce tu société en général mais
ça arrive même dans la communauté lgbt à
plusieurs reprises j'ai entendu des gens
du cru le président d'une association
les gens m'appelaient des perses je peux
dire qu'ils sont dans ma communauté
m'appeler président tu as appris fallait
que non je dis président ne m'appelle
pas présidente
mais moi je compte on est en panne entre
pas dans les classes dans le box que
prévu par tout le monde on doit être
vacciné contre le pétage de plombs sinon
on va qu'on a pété les plombs tout en
postant pourtant et on comprendra
pourquoi est ce que certaines personnes
de la communauté lgbt ce en entendant
cette arrogante
parce que il ya tout le temps les gens
ne comprennent pas comment est ce qu'il
doive rater devant eux
voilà au prétexte cherche à travers ces
histoires c'est que 1 en fonction de la
perception que les gens en du genre de
ces que doit être un an ils se sont
complètement trompés sur mon cas moi je
suis un homme je je suis peut-être pas
aussi comment dire je ne remplit pas
toutes les cases de l'agilité et tout ça
mais ma façon d'être homme ne fait pas
de 9,2 dis pas que je suis plus en cas
d'autres bien moins sommes qu'un autre
mais il s'agit de mon cas mais d'autres
d'autres personnes vivent des réalités
différentes
et ça ça veut pas dire qu'ils sont plus
au moins un homme par rapport à ça donc
[Musique]
j'allais arriver à cette conclusion pas
cette conclusion à ce fait que le
comportement d'une personne ne détermine
pas son genre
alors pas du tout dans cette société a
assez oppressante pour moi j'ai pris le
temps de de banaliser qui j'étais de
m'accepter tels que je suis et c'est
pour ça que j'ai toujours ce sourire qui
a du mal à quitter mon visage même
conceptrice 1
mais je sais qu'il ya d'autres personnes
qui ne ne supporte pas la pression
sociale
il ya eu des cas de suicide il ya des
personnes qui ne vit pas leur vie et
qu'ils ont toujours l'impression de
d'être dans la peau d'une autre personne
et je pense que on peut changer tout ça
et nous avons tous la responsabilité de
changer cela et ça commence par des
petites choses en arrêtant de
stigmatiser les gens à la limite quand
vous parler à une personne que vous ne
connaissez pas si pour vous cette
personne est une fille ou un nombre
utiliser la personne quand je suis en
train de faire la personne s'est mis au
moins là on n'est pas déterminée attire
les gens de quelqu'un c'est plus facile
pour ces personnes là que de dire il l
est de le mettre dans une case après et
quand une personne est trop différente
vous c'est pas mal non plus parce qu'au
final si vous êtes qui vous êtes et
quand vous accepte comme ça pourquoi
pourquoi ne pas faire part et une autre
personne qui ne veut pas nous avons nos
frères on se comporte comme ça avec des
inconnus est parfois avec nos plus
proches et ça fait très mal ça fait pas
si mal quand quand un inconnu du rejet
parce que c'est pas ma tasse de saveur
on ne mange pas dans les airs en citant
père quand c'est ton frère
alors là on guérir en guérit très
difficilement il faut faire attention
dans notre façon de communiquer avec nos
proches avec nos enfants
les aider à découvrir qu'ils sont et non
pas les déterminer en avance et pour
ceux qui m'écoutent qui sont là et qui
se sentent différents dans leur féminité
dans leur masculinité
c'est bien et c'est beau donc apprenez à
être vous même à vous accepter tels que
vous êtes passés de cette façon là que
vous serez et pagny ne cherchait pas à
correspondre à ce que la société nous
dicte chercher à correspondre chercher à
être en harmonie avec vous même dans
tout ce que vous êtes en train de faire
dans tous dans tout ce que vous
chercher à être donc en conclusion c'est
que je dirais c'est que j'ai envie de
partager
c'est que c'est que la meilleure façon
d'être homme pour ceux qui le sang et la
meilleure façon d'être femme c'est
d'être vous même
merci